[Musique]
la seule chose à faire pour le moment
c'est d'attendre attendre que cette
onzième tempête tropicale de la saison à
frapper la région soit passé on peut
dire que katrina a tout de même fait
beaucoup beaucoup de dégâts là bas pour
l'instant le fondateur de norbourg
vincent lacroix est introuvable
la décision de placer en faillite ces
entreprises n'arrêtent en rien l'anc est
criminel que mène la grc dans la sphère
norbourg on ne sait pas encore à quel
moment on pourra rassurer ceux qui
avaient placé leurs économies auprès de
norbourg meilleur top cette toute petite
localité de l'alberta est en deuil
une opération policière a pris fin dans
un atroce médecin quatre agents de la
grc ont été tués évidemment tout le
monde a un lien avec ces policiers là il
y en a trois qui travaillaient ici
[Musique]
ce soir rome est la capitale du monde
sait maintenant une période de deuil qui
commence avant les obsèques de jean paul
ii ce pape qui aura marqué toute une
génération
ça aura pris 24 heures pour élire un
nouveau pape joseph ratzinger était le
candidat pressenti le cabinet a
également approuvé le prolongement
controversé lui aussi de la barrière de
sécurité
les autorités israéliennes affirment que
toutes les colonies de gaza seront
démolis
les palestiniens eux ont fêté les
départs des derniers colons
8h51 8h56 9h17 9h47 heure de londres
donc voilà les moments des quatre
explosions survenues dans des endroits
différents de la ville
quatre attentats en moins d'une heure un
autobus cette station de métro ont été
touchées
un violent séisme de 7,6 sur l'échelle
de richter a détruit des dizaines de
villages dans le nord de l'inde et du
pakistan ce matin les cheveux minecraft
[Applaudissements]